the rise in poetry stars well you know
there's something we we published just
the other day I was work I really like
Michael Dickman his name is he's in at
least one problem The New Yorker
recently you know they're constantly
there's a woman called Kathleen grabber
who teaches at Princeton at the moment
though she was moving she moves around
they're always always always interesting
early career poets us we've learned to
call them we don't use that word young
or old anymore thank heavens
so absolutely they're always I mean you
nothing makes me happier but I'm sure
this is true of most poets I would like
to think it's true of them anyway
nothing makes me happier than the
thought that there's gonna be somebody
coming on the road who is going to be
sent elating I was going to take this
project that we're all involved in this
and more and more I think perhaps as a
feature of getting older one has it
realizes that if anything if anything
you know if one's lucky if one's lucky
ones just another drone in some sense
another tiller and you know another cure
another drawer of water another worker
in the vineyard or whatever we all are
you know and would be very lucky to be
counted one of them at all them be it an
Irish one an American one or any other
kind of one you know and you know I love
the idea actually more and more that we
do if we're lucky if we're lucky if the
guns are with us we might get to do a
little bit maybe I don't know if we
advance things I don't know if we
advance things you know I don't know if
we have advanced anything much but we
have moment because we've not advanced
on John Donne or with
Shakespeare we simply have not or Emily
Dickinson no way no way of we advanced
on that so what each of us is doing is
if we're lucky is just to the variations
on that and maybe these and Frost's
great phrase these momentary stays
against confusion that in some sense
must be must be new
they must be new making it new just but
their very nature they have not quite
had this particular shape in the world
they've not taken this form in the world
these words have not occurred in
precisely this order but having said all
that there is nothing so exciting as the
prospect of of the next generation
coming along and and doing their breath
village you know